what's up everyone welcome back
to an all-new season of coffee and
commerce super excited to be with my
co-host and the legend himself mr gary
vaynerchuk
thank you zubin it's great to see you
you're looking good cleanly shaved
looking fresh
excited to be back for season two i know
we have a big time guest and uh you know
the e-commerce world continues to evolve
in such a fun way
uh in an important way and
i'm excited to be here with you likewise
so to kick things off
given where we are from a macro
standpoint there uh are talks of
recession we've got capital tightening
in the marketplace
so we want to bring as much value as
possible so we decided who better to
bring
than someone whose company
crushed it in the last economic downturn
in the last economic uncertainty scott
boylan ceo of all star so we're bringing
scott in right now scott's company was
created the snuggie perhaps the biggest
hit of the last recession so there's a
ton to learn from him
i love that i'm excited to have him here
and real quick while he's coming on
board just want to say what's up to cody
bell
and samuel miller and to scott gilbert
and to dustin ruther and tc i mean the
the susan on linkedin thomas mchugh so a
lot of fun a lot of people in the
comments we see you i see you i want to
say what's up thank you so much mark
russell good to see you morgan owen
bowler brown that was a mouthful
uh robert hill's a lot easier uh great
to see all of you thanks for being here
and uh let's bring him in because you're
right the snuggie really
um is a case study that i personally
admire
[Music]
what's going on guys
what's up brother scott
all good all good
i also admire scott's gun scott you work
out my bro
the shirt bro
i appreciate it we do what we can
do and take us away
scott great to have you um like i said
at the onset
so with the economic uncertainty that
we're in right now we want this episode
to be focused on innovating and not just
innovating but selling and making money
during economic uncertainty so we got
scott boylan ceo of star the company
behind the snuggie welcome scott
thank you
thanks for having me
absolutely so scott take us back um many
of us
last
time we had economic uncertainty massive
economic uncertainty 0.708 the one
product that came out and was a case
study for pretty much everyone about how
to innovate when there are downturns how
to create products that consumers want
and how to make money in any environment
and everyone kept talking about the
snuggie and this is your first interview
or first podcast ever talking about the
snuggie so we're super excited for that
tell us about that journey
no it was really interesting so it was
about 2008 and
i get asked all the time because it was
one of the first viral campaigns right
and how did you create that and they
called me up and it's a pretty easy
answer we didn't create anything i still
don't believe you could create a total
viral virality but you got here as you
always say we didn't like that fire we
were smart enough to blow on it but when
you really look at the snuggie and like
how do you make money in a downturn you
almost have to peel it back a few years
because i think companies that say okay
there's a downturn now we're going to
seize on opportunities it's really
strong companies
that are sustainable and understand how
to win and profit wins right so all
these companies that come into these
downturns they're usually growth
companies and high level companies and
when a problem happens they have none of
the fundamentals and none of the
strategies to succeed so you know we had
a bumpy ride up right it was you know
we're a self-funded company we started
it you know did everything from two
three people at that point we probably
had
40 and by the end of it we had 60. so we
had grown every part of that company in
every penny matter from sourcing to
logistics to finance to how we marketed
and when 2008 2009 happened we were just
opportunistic right and i can fast
forward to today what happened then is
big companies and i don't understand
this media drops half the rate and they
run away because there's a recession so
media blows wide open so we just happen
to have the right product at the right
time and we don't pick them like i don't
see a recession coming say okay we got
to jump all over that we have a detailed
testing model we test hundreds of items
we put them on tv we test them on web we
test them all over the place and the
consumer decides so we just happen to
have the right product at the right time
that made people feel good now why did
it blow up because we were good at
everything else we were able to make a
million a week we had relationships at
walmart that got the front of the store
we knew how to run tv and we knew how to
jump all over it wasn't hard i mean we
don't have to be mathematicians that
when we buy meteor in july for a blanket
and then it's half the price in november
it's going to triple in response and
quadruple so just everything worked in
that time to make that win and i always
say profit wins right so if you're
really driving and driving towards a
profitable company when bad times happen
you have the strength to succeed
smart
yeah no it's really funny listening to
that
direct mail
radio print
you know television in the 60s and 70s
remnant tv cable tv
google adwords is how i did it
uh tick tock is how some people are
doing it today it's always the same
story in different versions which is you
have actual operators that know where
the consumer attention is they take
advantage of an arbitrage he just
explained perfectly his which was
we were agnostic if the math works the
math works and when coca-cola and bmw go
away because they're not real you know
they're executives
like that's just the truth at the end of
the day they're executives and your
entrepreneurial practitionership gave
you that advantage when i you know
zooming when i look at the comments
so many more people can associate with
that story now they may not have the
budgets to do it on tv the way he did
but they can do that today right this
second
on youtube shorts for no media exposure
the virality's there
people
don't recognize the moment and i think
when listening to that that was a big
story of recognizing the moment
yeah and it's about chasing the win
right so you have to be nimble enough to
see these opportunities and big enough
to take advantage of them but like gary
just said small companies can still take
advantage of them also you just have to
see where they are and be nimble enough
to react to them and have all of your
foundational principles right and then
just lean in i think some of these times
are better to lean in
there's going to be brands out there
bought right now there's just there's a
lot of headwinds out there but there's
still tremendous opportunities
you know the other thing that struck a
chord with me scott and what you've
mentioned was profitability and i think
that
the reason why gary and i started
working with one another to begin with
was because that's the thing that we
connected on which was so many of these
direct consumer brands and it's not to
say it's a bad thing they took vc
funding private equity funding whatnot
and so the goal of that organization
is not necessarily to make money in fact
it's oftentimes not to make money at the
cost of user acquisition or new
customers and now fast forward where we
are right now we're seeing it in the
market companies aren't getting
financing unless they're profitable
and we're back to these business
fundamentals that had almost been
forgotten over the past few years uh
talk to us a little bit about how you
maintained
and still do with your other products
profitability even when something is
blowing up as fast as it is
so we we we advertise a little different
than a lot of companies we're a complete
roast model we're old school as seen on
tv we actually started off in direct
mail freestanding inserts credit card
things we use advertising
to fund our basically
we use advertising to fund the campaign
like anybody else but we may spend 10
million dollars and we make eight
million dollars back in profit so in
fact that advertising only cost us two
million dollars so we had an 80 return
on ad spend so the way we do it on a
direct to consumer basis and providing
value that way direct shipping and
having every cost and everything line
allows us to run triple the media of
another company maybe five times the
media of another company you just
brought something interesting to me
because
you know five years ago
if i wasn't so strong in my convictions
i would have thought i was a dinosaur
that was getting extinct because i would
go to trade shows and i had kids and i
would say their kids because they were
21 years old and i'm not right and they
would tell me retail's dead
and i said you guys i've been doing this
a long time one thing you have to know
is there's two things there's a pendulum
that shifts all over the place you have
to be selling all places you we learned
a long time ago
you can't tell your consumer where to
buy you have to be where they want to
buy now that's not everybody's model but
that's our model so to not be at retail
so many of these companies were all over
facebook instagram well what happens ios
14 and their one channel gets shut down
that's right be everywhere right now and
let your consumer have that the other
thing that happened i was with a group
and i really thought it was an
interesting opportunity for us to
partner on brands and they told me my
model is broken
we will never be able to sell anything
we will never build a brand for one
reason
we make profit and that's crushing our
valuations that's right it's like you
have to and this was a guy from harvard
worked in one of the biggest banks
raised a ton of money on this spectrum i
go i've just seen this over too many
years that's early day internet that's
early profit wins sustainable businesses
win and that's what we're seeing right
now i mean it's it's it really goes back
i mean it's real i mean i you know again
i think we're all kind of like
high-fiving here but like it's exciting
i want everybody to hear this like in
what world
in what world
could a simple statement as profit is
bad be real of course there's i don't
invest here's where profit can be bad if
somebody wants to be a stickler
you're taking all the money out of the
business to buy corvettes and boats and
you're not doing the right thing by the
business and eventually the golden goose
dies oftentimes by a second generation
operator whether it's a family business
or a difference fine but
other than that to your point the logic
around this it makes me it makes me
laugh
how people don't understand tried and
true things are real we we have this
almost
infatuation to make up new variables
when some of this like i'll give you a
great one
somehow
people have decided hard work is not
part of the equation
you know like people like to razz me
like gary you go too hard i'm like no no
no no i say if you want something
extraordinary
you've got to put in the work for some
reason back to
the nice compliment i gave you when we
see muscles and of course there's
steroids in hd i get it but like there's
work
and like i hear people like gary you
don't get it i don't work hard i work
smart i'm like cool i work hard and
smart now what
like you know like like i people try to
reinvent truths like work ethic
i i am the number one [ __ ] fan on
earth of mental health i am the least
anxious
i
literally wake up kissing the world
because i'm grateful for the lack of
anxiety
i am
i sleep eight hours a day i believe in
it the most i'm all about all these
things yet just because i believe in
work ethic
people try to paint a fake narrative and
try to actually debate me on this notion
i've got a big news alert for everybody
hard work ethic is part of the equation
towards
outsized success it's part of the
equation the end and profit
to your point like when did not making
money sound like a good idea i will
never understand that no it's insane i
was at a uh i was in a
basically i lectured i didn't lecture
i've never really lectured like this my
first podcast i was asked to
guest speak at syracuse university at
their entrepreneurship programs probably
12 years ago around snuggie um
and somebody asked me what's your key to
be an entrepreneurial success and i said
you know no one's ever asked me that
before
so just give me one second i said here's
the only thing i could tell you if
you're in a room with 100 other
entrepreneurs i can guarantee you there
are smarter people in you i could also
guarantee you you'll be the hardest
working person there and if you are you
will find success you just have to find
your path this is very important ryan
goes so how do you keep a good work
ethic without getting burned out two
things popped to my mind i'd love to
hear from you both because you've had
your successes and they're real one when
you genuinely love the thing you're
doing you're playing yeah like like i'm
not doing it for the money i'm doing it
because i like being an entrepreneur the
way people like sailing and eating pizza
and watching movies and playing golf so
that's one way this is why i've always
loved passion
number two here's a big one i love it
the most i love it the most comma
if i wake up and it's raining outside
and it's just kind of shitty day i'm
okay with having an off day off week off
month on the grind
because i'm not gonna judge myself in a
nanosecond of a 60-year career and so
it's about having a relationship of
self-love that you don't beat yourself
up if you've had a bad quarter let alone
a bad day thoughts man
so you're definitely more evolved than
me um you know because i love some of
the things you're saying i think you
know somebody gave me a comment the
other day that i took as a as they took
us and so it's a self no it wasn't an
insult it was a self-reflection they
said somebody said oh scott's still
working and the other guy goes he
hustles like he's 25 years old and
doesn't have a penny to his name and
some of that is a little bit true and
maybe it's too true some of it's fear of
losing some of it's love winning right
and i do love what i do and i want to
achieve and now we're partnering with a
lot of smaller brands
and i will tell you some of the youth
there i mean i
i live for energy i feed off energy
right so
some of these younger kids that are
building brands have such well they have
one thing for them and one thing against
them they've tremendous positivity and i
love that but they don't have a plan
right so you need everybody has a thing
so positivity with a plan we're help
putting a plan around them so working
with them to do things that we've never
been good at really just focusing on
that brand and micro in that brand and
putting it on our platform really really
gives me energy but
i'll do this 25 more years real quick
liz goes i know he caters to the young
people but at 60 year olds i love this
guy i just want everybody to know on the
record since i've got this great
opportunity with liz
i surely do not cater to the young
i think what what you're seeing how old
are you my friend
liz or me yeah you 55 right
55 46
and we
are young here because we like it i
cater to
that energy not what the birth
certificate says
i think because of the platforms i put
out content i'm not doing shark tank i'm
doing tick tock sure it looks like it to
the young but i'm catering to the
practical optimists and if you listen to
what he just said
they have the youth and excitement but
they don't have the plan i'm obsessed
with optimism when people hear optimism
they think delusion i don't i think
optimism is actually the single most
practical human trait to being an
entrepreneur but it has to be grounded
in reality when i have people roll up to
me and being like i'm going to be a
billionaire i'm like cool and my next
question is how
like well i'm going to grind for it i'm
like that's not going to be it like and
so like you know those are the
conversations
yeah i love you
i would i would think some of the
younger people you know and maybe that i
was like this when i first started out
but they're so linear right here's my
plan and this ape is going to happen b
is going to happen c is going to happen
and i'm going to be a billionaire or
these are the five steps i'm going to do
in my career i'm going to work here i'm
going to go to this bank i'm going to go
here and i'm like you're like a stick in
the stream right you're going to get
dropped in there and i i think your
positivity and you're smart as can be
you're going to get to the bottom but if
you don't realize you're going to bounce
off all these rocks and let that stream
take you you're going to get stuck right
so i think that's the energy you need
but you got to be able to be nimble and
flow
and it's because they don't have the
experience so they have the pattern
recognition to go last time i try to do
this and go linearly i had to go left
and right and forward and backwards and
it's totally fine with that so the thing
i was going to mention earlier i think
for both of you having spent time with
both of you the reason why
you have that work life balance or
whatever you want to call it
is because you enjoy what you do and
you're helping other people as you do it
in conversations with scott he's always
mentioned me like disproportionately
give to the people that work for you
versus like what you're taking
gary i mean i've been working now for
gary for the last three years and i
cannot say enough great things about him
but one of the things i'll tell you is
he surrounded himself with people that
are
kind and want to help and more
importantly
do this not only for their own benefit
but to benefit him
i think that's a really important point
in terms of partnerships to find those
people that you want to win
it's all the same thing right uh there's
a guy in the comments right now saying
did djt love goes
stop lying you guys is full of [ __ ] he
goes you all didn't hustle you guys got
lucky and i think a lot about
the makeup
of that comment and like really
believing in that life is so about
perspective when you talk you were just
talking and he was commenting and i was
thinking i'm like man
when when when i you know zubin you know
under the hood but like when we're here
this is public and i'm very empathetic
to people being cynical or like not
fully trusting we live in a very complex
world and
i i think it's so practical to be
optimistic and give to others because i
i really think when you do good things
happen to you i just actually think it's
very logical
but i was also raised by an optimistic
mother
my father was raised by a pessimistic
mother and he's more like my friend in
the comments here you guys got lucky
it's cynical it's a jealousy and envy
framework and i don't see that as a bad
thing i don't get mad at that comment i
actually have deep compassion for it the
reason i like to do this the reason i
say yes to this show why i wanted to be
on today is
we're like
if one per you know when he says you're
sell it i have nothing to sell like like
look this is i don't there's no
mastermind there's no marketing like
there's nothing to sell it's the idea of
if one person watching right now alex t
rick williams
derek baker if one human
hears any one of us three say something
in a way they have never heard it before
or
how about this my favorite one say
something they've heard 13 times before
but today wednesday september 7th
2022 at 4 36 eastern 1 36 pacific was
the exact moment they were ready to
[ __ ] hear it and go you know what i
have been excuse oriented or i have been
you know not accountable or i haven't
taken advantage of the arbitrages of
what these guys are talking about then
that's like the best feeling because the
emails i get
from people saying this video in 2016
changed the course of my life and my
family's life
is way more delicious than another zero
on my bank account
you know
so he says you got lucky right so in
some ways you could say he's right right
but you put yourself in more positions
to be lucky and that goes back to the
grind right you know
i i snug he was lucky we had the right
product at the right time we were able
to take advantage of it we have 50
failures before that right so you have
to keep grinding it out and putting
yourself in position and building that
platform so in some ways he's right
there's some luck involved i would guess
i would argue any human being watching
this right now is obnoxiously lucky your
parents have sex at the exact right
second to make you a human being 400
trillion to one
modern scientists mathematical odds of
being a human being i don't want to hear
a word from anybody's [ __ ] mouth
everyone's lucky your mom could have got
up for another glass of wine and you
wouldn't exist all right great
i mean that conversation is ridiculous
there's people who literally had a tree
fall in her head today they were unlucky
right i was [ __ ] i'm the luckiest i
was traded for wheat i was born in the
soviet union a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
[ __ ] was able to be traded for wheat
because of a lucky moment in cold war
history ended up being america the
entrepreneurial heaven of all time as an
entrepreneur
i'm 100 lucky good now what my big thing
to my friends and acquaintances and
strangers who use luck as a weapon to
make themselves feel better is
okay and now what did that make you feel
better cool we're all lucky now what
all right great
i don't know
you get you're like making that in or
what did you kind of i'm i'm i'm just
taking it all in look i uh
totally agree with both of you i think
that
there's luck in everything but it's also
i think goes back to what you're
mentioning about
parents upbringing and
having a pessimistic outlook on things
or an optimistic outlook on things there
was a gentleman i think uh who was just
whose comment just popped up that he's
been making money for other people for
many years and he's barely scraping by
and
what i'll say
is that
there are many ways to look at that
but the one of the ways to look at that
is if you can make money for one person
you can make money for a lot of people
and if you can make money for other
people make money for people who value
you
and allow you to make money alongside
them
and not this zero-sum game that i'm
gonna extract as much as i can from you
i'm reading it too i just saw his
comment i'm devastated working 16 to 18
hours a day for somebody else who's
treating you like [ __ ] but then my brain
goes to like
[ __ ] you gotta quit you just like
like
if you're in control and that is like
powerful to believe in like i say all
the time to my friends
everybody here knows the last 15 years
of politics have been decisive i have
had democrat and republican friends tell
me if this guy wins the election or if
this girl wins the election i'm moving
to canada meanwhile every republican and
democrats still [ __ ] here right but
what i remind those friends when they're
crying when it's not their four-year
eight-year era i remind them
sweden's available new zealand's open
you want to be bitcoined out el
salvador's ready for you like it's
inconvenient uh by the way a lot of my
friends moved to miami to not pay taxes
now they're moving back because they're
bored because new york's back in open i
don't know like you're in control do
your [ __ ] thing
no i listen you mentioned being an
entrepreneur right and how you got lucky
and everything and that was you know a
bunch of years ago there's never been a
better time in the history of the united
states to be an entrepreneur i mean
everything we've done you know shopify
has democratized everything going direct
to the consumer i mean you talk about
the great resignation there are
opportunities out there i've seen kids
make millions of dollars from the
kitchen table just doing amazon that's
right when that started i said if i had
a criticism of my company and myself
it's almost not being nimble enough
right we're on as seen on tv we missed
early days facebook right you're jumping
on tick tock or a year too late right
you got to be able to take advantage of
the opportunities and sometimes they're
right in front of you and you can do i
mean the great thing i hear you know
because i i get so frustrated carry also
some of the things you said you know
work-life balance is great but you still
got to work right doesn't mean it's just
all balance but i love this side hustle
concept right that's the first time i
started hearing about that as the last
you know seven eight nine years and some
of these kids are crushing it they're
working full-time jobs and they're
building businesses on the side and then
they're taking them and they have
businesses and they did it from a
kitchen table because you could do that
these days right it comes down to big
companies small company what are your
fundamentals what's your path to
profitability you know what's your plan
and then build from there and that's in
every segment of business that we go
into or anybody goes into
i think perspective is just incredible
like i
once you have the emotional strength to
have compassion for others
all these things i think about it
constantly like
so much of why i'm so outward
with my persona
is because i can handle the negativity
because i deal with it as not an
indication to me but i do i i come from
a place of gratitude that i'm not in
that place and i want more good for them
even when they're telling me i suck [ __ ]
yeah and trying to and trying to plan
your everything is impossible right and
that's where you really just gotta roll
yes about snuggy right and we were the
first viral campaign there was no barely
any social media
anything i want everybody to see what
just happened dgt love just said i
apologize if i've offended anyone i'm
working the life out of me and i'm being
drained this is something i want
everybody who's been watching to watch i
love this dude and instead of what most
people do on shows like this when he was
coming with the heat early on and
somebody behind the scenes would have
banned him or the public face that's
paying attention like me with a [ __ ] on
him we come with real conversations and
empathy we had a conversation here for
the last 10 minutes and look what it
leads to and this is the civility
that this country desperately needs we
have to have like of course people
should see the world differently we come
from different angles different perspe
but we have to have the capacity
to not be in such conflict and that's
how you lead to great things in
organizations in governments in families
and like i'm excited about that this
like made my day this gt love post it
made my day
and no one was offended like not one bit
i know that if
he's gonna come here and say the things
he was saying trying to hurt us
it means he was hurting yeah
i don't know i just anyway i know we got
a little side off track here's what i
would like to say because then i've got
to bounce and you guys maybe can
continue
the story of you just completely rocked
me with my favorite thing
all the companies ran away we ran
towards it
and and honestly to tie in what we
talked about for the last 10 minutes of
mindset
in business and in life
the game is very simple
you either stare fear in the face
or you run away from it and i would
argue that when the economy gets soft
and people run away that is reacting to
the fear and there are people like our
our fine man here who ran into the
opportunity i think with
all the things we're talking about with
mindset and perspective it's either you
are running away from the fear or you're
understanding fear's not scary we all
lose we all make mistakes we failed
listen what he said we failed 50 times
but and and that's
it's very real and like i don't know if
there's a day that doesn't go by where i
do tons of mistakes dumb [ __ ] big
mistakes sometimes a full year i can
think of three years in a row where i
don't think i was at my best running
this company but the last two years
being a [ __ ] on fire
closes all those gaps
and how much time do you think every
time you fail
um
usually not very long mainly because i
don't value other people saying i'm good
i'm bad meaning
the thing that allows me to live my
public life is when everyone says i'm
the goat or i'm the best or you're a
genius i don't believe them either i'm
not a piece of [ __ ]
but i'm also not the greatest of all
time i'm just trying to do my thing out
here and i stayed down that middle
but what i think i'm getting at is that
you don't sit there and sulk
about one thing after another so i can
move on get to the next thing take that
because i'm next
because i'm not looking to use sulking
or excuses
as a thing to propel me and prop me up
in the eyes of my contemporaries yeah i
i like to i like to take failure and say
okay what do i learn from it all right
and how did i how did i get better from
that and how does that prepare luckily
enough we keep our failures to a minimum
that nothing's ever brought us down you
know you know you mentioned
you know and you surround yourself with
good people it helps because i'm an
optimist by like they they call
scoptimism in my company right so i
never see anything as bad right so i
need somebody sometimes to say hey this
isn't working right we need to take a
look at what's happening here i know you
believe in it i have a sign in my office
that says never fall in love with the
product because i can't tell you how
many games i have and six different
times that redo their creativity change
it i love that that's right i love i
love i'm so the same way like i always
think i'm right but in the face of being
wrong i'm like [ __ ] i'm wrong and
that humility and like i love that
anyway i gotta run i'll let you guys go
and we'll talk soon thank you sir
that the consumer decides and that's
what's going to work exactly to your
point that's what i was going to mention
one of the things that uh from a vayner
media standpoint uh was employed i think
last year uh in this vayner volume model
of creative was the notion that
we are not
arrogant enough for whatever word you
want to use to assume that we know
what's right what will resonate
with consumers we will put a ton out
there and determine what does resonate
with them and allow them to figure out
what that is now i think from your
perspective what's unique
and i'd love for you to kind of talk
about this and all-star is your ability
to either take products that exist or
create new products and test a ton and
figure out what works because there are
a lot of folks
watching right now that are interested
in direct consumers have done stuff
and most probably they've only done one
or two things and they haven't really
tested enough to figure out what's going
to work for them and what are they going
to be passionate about and what are
consumers going to care about
yeah so you can never pick a product
right you you just can't right you could
pick products that fit certain metrics
that could work for direct to consumer
campaign does it solve a problem is
there a white spay doesn't it but the
end of the day the consumer has to want
it right so we have a testing model that
starts with surveys and we have
probably 10 000 items put through this
so it's a learning model that gets
better each time so we put items through
surveys we'll do a quick little web test
we may make a prototype and put it on
facebook or instagram before you go to
market just so everyone understands
before you go to market you've got an
idea for a concept you put it out in a
survey to understand what kind of demand
there is out there
based on the demographic that you think
is i guess
and we're not predicting success they
were predicting failure our goal is to
eliminate and minimize the amount of
items that we actually
spend money on shooting commercials and
doing creatives and the end of the day
it's the consumer that decides if we you
know if we manufacture 5 000 pieces and
we bring it in and we sell 100
there's nobody there if we do a couple
of ads and we put it out on facebook
instagram tick tock or if we even do a
tv spot and we blow through it in a week
well then we have a big winner and we
always say our products sell at retail
100 of the time because if they're gonna
buy it direct to consumer from a company
they never heard of it's absolutely
gonna work when we build that awareness
right so it's building the whole
ecosystem up so it's a test and learn
model now i've seen it done differently
so some of the young brands that are
developing they take one item and they
believe in it and they will go through
so many iterations and we love
partnering with these companies because
many times when they bring it to us and
they're doing four million dollars in
sales that's after three years the first
year they did 150 000 they talked to
everybody from a customer service basis
they learned everything about that
product they kept iterating based on
what they learned and what their brand
was that's a different model but that's
a fantastic model and some of the big
success stories of single product
companies are absolutely being obsessed
with their brand and their product and
learning from it and then we just take
it and blow it up right because we put
it into our platform we could do
everything else 100 and i think that
a couple of things there one
the market's changed uh there's a
comment in here
um about
the trying to find the comment here but
around the fact that what worked before
um is it necessarily gonna work uh in
the future and it's from dust and back
old frameworks
uh aren't futuristic i think that
applies thank you that applies across
the board so what do i mean by that one
it has to do with like product creation
ideation all of that before years ago
and even more recently larger cpgs they
go through a long process to ideate
create products it's often insulated
from consumers by the time they go to
market
they basically just created it in a
bubble no one's actually ever seen it
heard of it etc and they're just hoping
that it works
the other framework that i think is
really important to get away from
now let's take a step back if we take a
look at direct consumer when it first
started early 2000s late 90s there was
not much consumer demand to buy off of a
com that you'd never heard of
and there wasn't much capital in the
market meaning investors weren't lined
up banks weren't lined up to loan money
some brands started they got a little
bit of traction
fast forward like 2005
you start getting some um software like
shopify that comes into the mix so you
have technology that's enabling it
you've got capital that's coming in from
an investment standpoint banks are
funding it and consumer demand is
growing
all of that basically culminates into
what we experienced in 2020 2021
and at the first half of this year which
was massive amounts of capital
being available and accessible to direct
to consumer brands small and large and
consumer demand was there but what
happened
markets shifted economic uncertainty
90 percent of the brands
that
we were exposed to that scott was
talking about earlier were not focused
on profit they were focused on customer
growth because the folks that invested
in them weren't interested in taking
money off the table they wanted them to
go from 50 million dollars losing a
million a year to a hundred million
dollars in revenue losing five million a
year because it was a larger company
they could exit at a larger multiple
capital dries up and back to frameworks
shifting we've got to go back the irony
is
old frameworks aren't futuristic but
there are older frameworks that are
futuristic and they're what we talk
about in terms of business fundamentals
and really thinking back and saying hey
look at the pizza store down the pizza
shop down the street or the restaurant
these companies these restaurants these
small businesses across dry cleaners
they're not out there just getting net
new customers and spending as much money
as they can so they can do your laundry
once or sell you pizza once they survive
based on providing great service a great
product and getting people to come back
and that's the framework and that's the
big shift that if you're a fortune 500
cpg all the way down to
starting a product company in your
garage you've got to focus on retention
you've got to focus on making sure
customers get value and targeting those
to get the most value and building your
business there so with that scott tell
us a little bit about
your customer testing again and when you
find traction what do you do how do you
scale kind of these opportunities
yeah so what makes us unique is is
really our speed if this is one thing
that makes us unique it's our speed
right so if you go to
png or some other big cpg company it's
like you said it's a five-year process
pretty much done in a bubble they'll put
a big marketing spam behind it and they
hope it sells
we're testing live right we're gonna
believe in products that we survey we're
gonna make a product we're gonna put it
into the marketplace and you know what
surveys are worth they're they're an
indication
you know what really is the vote your
credit card right so when consumers vote
with their credit card that they want
their product once we have that we are
all systems go we know we have a winner
we know we could advertise it we know
there's consumer demand where we do most
of our manufacturing china but we do
some in the united states we're ramping
up to be able to make huge quantities
we're placing it in every retailer we're
advertising it everywhere and we're just
ready to go right so we have products
that sometimes go from test to mass
retail distribution in eight months
right that's almost unheard of right
there and that's probably one of the
uniqueness of an old school as seen on
tv company that grew up in that it was
always a speed game it was always a race
to market game now we've just put a lot
more fundamentals over around it
so let's go to one other topic here a
couple of topics here one you talked
about retail i think it was a very
important point you brought up and i
want to
double down on this here you mentioned
that if somebody is going to buy from a
com they've never heard of
a product imagine what they'll do in
retail when they go into a target when
they go into a walmart where the
credibility of the product is
essentially the store we've seen it
you've seen it even the buyer profiles
of these big box retailers are shifting
they're bringing people in that have
direct consumer experience and they need
and they ask for drive to consumer
success regardless of your
organizational size to have you on the
shelf so can you talk to us a little bit
about
because i wholeheartedly agree with you
on not just selling on one channel and
when we talk about retail
when we talk about kind of succeeding in
retail can you talk to us about some of
the trends you're seeing in retail and
how the folks that are listening in can
maximize their opportunity to get into
retail and succeed
yeah so i think selling a retail if
anything it de-risks you right so when
you're in any one channel whether it be
just retail just amazon just your own
ddc site i mean look what happened to
all these companies with ios 14 they
were facebook instagram companies that
kind of went away so selling the retail
will be risky but retail is really where
all the volume is and it still is right
i would say 60 70 80 percent of our
volume on any one campaign is from our
retail sales because that's where the
consumer are people say they're not
shopping at retail the average customers
in walmart i think two point something
times a week now retailers are changing
they you know i had a senior vp at one
of the largest retailers in the world
say to me we like ddc companies because
you talk with your customers not at them
so we're not just telling them we're
taking you know some of our best product
innovation comes from consumer insights
it comes from the early d2c sales it
determines how people are using it that
changes packaging they ask for different
features so sometimes by the time we go
to retail the product has evolved but
you need a great quality product that
could last a long time on the shelf
because retailers want people very happy
with the products that are coming in i
think some of the trends they're less
promotional based they're more branded
based right now they're not just looking
for single hot deals they're looking for
products with long-term staying power
but certain retailers are leaning in
like you know target wants to be known
as a place where all the native brands
go and they have a unique customer
coming in am i getting new customers in
so walmart's now playing in some of that
space too the clubs have actually done a
real good job for a real long time doing
that so retailers are just another
shopping but they're just another
shopping portal is all they are
yeah and i think that um
it's it's really important when you're
starting out right to think through
where your product fits
have some ideas about it both in terms
of the consumer you're targeting as well
as the retailers you ultimately want to
get into and then
have those kind of the ability to test
these things and go out to market you
don't have to spend a lot of money with
the tools that are out there available
to you right now
you can spend a minimal amount of money
we're talking about like hundreds of
dollars to figure out and get some
traction
on what works um jose velazquez
commented on youtube
and i think it's a it's a great point he
said so the goal is to get your proof of
demand asap so you can scale it
and it goes both ways it's proof of
demand as well as
fail as fast as you can right
there was a
gentleman we used to work with uh lauren
paddleford at uh shopify uh he was a gm
over there shopify plus master
salesperson
um
he would get you into his framework
wherever you were but one of the things
i loved about what he said is get them
to know as fast as you can
and if you get them to know you're not
wasting your time with somebody who is
eventually going to get to know it's the
same with products it's the same with
everything we're talking about here
because if you get a no then you move on
to the next thing scott
yeah here's the negative on retail right
so i agree with that 100 right you want
to lean in on your winners right and get
out of your losers as fast as you can
that goes back to never falling in love
with a product and i only say that
because i fall in love with so many
products and you lose significant money
chasing products that consumers don't
want yeah but
the issue
out there right now for some of the
smaller companies is you know i talk
about starting businesses on your
kitchen table and amazon makes that real
simple right the way their platform
works the way they handle fulfillment
you could do things small and you've
seen a ton of small shopify startups
right that do a really good job retail
requires a knowledge base and
infrastructure so when you're ready to
go to retail that is the point where you
better partner with some companies or
bring in some senior level expertise
that knows the logistics that knows how
to sell retail because there's a lot
that goes into that a lot more than
shipping direct to the consumer so
that's the point so when you say
building up yeah prove your scale
really prove it out but when you're
ready to go to retail make sure you have
the right partnerships or
you bring in the right people to help
you
speaking of which perfect segue there
are people asking in the comments how
they can get in touch with you scott uh
you mind giving them your url and
however else you want them to get in
touch with you yeah we're at
www.allstarnovations.com
um
that's probably the best way to get in
touch with us you know as i said i've
never done a podcast so really not get
that many forward inwards it's a lot of
relationship stuff but yeah we'll
absolutely reach back out to you
um and i'll figure out a better way to
connect if people start coming in
amazing final question for you and
thanks to everyone who's tuned in i hope
you got a lot out of this
final question for scott so thinking
back on the snuggie and the success you
had when most brands were fighting just
merely for survival what was the biggest
surprise for you in taking the product
to market and what did you learn
that you
kind of take top of mind with you in
everything you do
um keep talking
not to try to pre-plan anything the
virality of it was completely unplanned
as i said there was no virality back
then right if i would go to vaynermedia
right now and say i have a new product i
want to make sure you have oprah wearing
it and you're going to get me on good
morning america it's going to be on
every news channel and it'll be the
number one viral video how much would
that cost me you could be like we can't
do that you can't guarantee those things
so
learning just to to follow the path
that's there and then to just lean in
what it is if there was a mistake in
snuggie and we're bringing a lot more
snuggy back 12 years in we launched it
we have we've spent millions of dollars
watching so many other brands snuggie
has so much more brand recognition but
we kind of stop pursuing it we still
sell them but snuggie stands for so much
more it's fun it's fashion right so that
was a learning lesson that when you get
those things that really respond to
people and you talk about in recession
why do people buy snuggies so much you
made them feel good right for 14.99 it
brought a smile to their face and it was
everybody's you know white elephant gift
so
that was probably the number one
learning is to
follow the path that is don't just go
linear with it right take those things
lean into them and go where go where the
tide's going
brilliant scott thank you so much for
your time
i appreciate it zubin
really enjoyed it thanks everyone for
tuning in and we'll be back with another
episode in just a few weeks see ya